- [Voiceover] We're asked to describe
the behavior of the function q around
its vertical asymptote at x = -3,
and like always, if
you're familiar with this,
I encourage you to pause it and see if you
can get some practice, and if you're not,
well, I'm about to do it with you.
All right, so this is q of x, it's defined
by a rational expression,
and whenever I'm dealing
with asymptotes, I like
to factor the numerators
and the denominators so I can
make more sense of things.
So the numerator here, what
two numbers if I were...
Their product is two
and their sum is three,
well that's two and one,
so I can factor this
as x + 1 times x + 2, if
that's unfamiliar to you,
I recommend you watch the videos
on Khan Academy about
factoring quadratics,
and over x + 3, and when
x = -1, or x = -2, it would
make the numerator equal zero
without making the denominator equal zero,
so those are points where the function
is equal to zero, but when x = -3,
the denominator equals
zero, while the numerator
is not equal to zero, so
we're dividing by zero,
and so that's a pretty good
sign of a vertical asymptote,
that our function as
we approach that value
is either going to pop up like that,
or it's going to pop down, or it's going
to pop down like that, or maybe,
or either way, or could pop up like that,
or it could go down something like that,
but we're going to have
a vertical asymptote
that the function as you approach x = -3,
that the function is going to approach
either positive infinity
or negative infinity
or it might do positive infinity
from one direction or negative infinity
from another direction and if this idea
of directionality is a
little bit confusing,
well that's where we're,
that's what we're about
to address in this video.
Let me just draw a number line here
that focuses on these interesting values.
So we care about x = -3, and then
the other interesting values may be -2,
- 1, it's all there, now what does it mean
to be approaching x, what does it mean
for x to be approaching -3
from the negative direction?
And just to be clear, this little
superscript right over here,
that means we're approaching
from the negative direction.
So that means we're
approaching from values
more negative than -3, so those
are these values right over here.
We are approaching, we are
approaching from that direction.
Another way to think
about it is we approach
from the negative direction
where on the interval
x is less than -3, so let's think about
what the sign of q of x is going
to be as we're approaching -3 from that
negative direction, from the left.
Well, if we have something less than -3,
and you add one, this
is going to be negative.
If you have something less than -3,
and you add two, that's
going to be negative as well,
and if you have something less than -3,
and you add three, well that's
going to be negative as well.
So a negative times a
negative is a positive,
but then you divide by
a negative, it's going
to be a negative, so q of x is going
to be negative on that interval.
So as we approach, we have
our vertical asymptote.
As we approach -3 from the left hand side,
well q of x is going to be negative
and so it's going to
approach negative infinity.
So as x approaches -3 from
the negative direction,
q of x is going to
approach negative infinity.
So at least this accurate,
this is accurate,
and this is accurate right over here,
and you can validate
that, try some values out.
Try negative, let's see, if you did
negative three point...
q of negative three point,
- 3.1, once again,
that's on the left side,
it might be like right over there.
Actually, it'd probably
be a little bit further.
It might be something like this,
like the scale that I've drawn it on.
q of -3.1, if you wanted to verify it,
it's going to be -3.1 + 1, which is -2.1,
times -3.1 + 2, which is negative,
- 1.1, 1.1, I could
put that in parentheses
just to make it clear, and then all
of that is going to be over,
well -3.1 + 3 is going to be,
is going to be -0.1.
So notice whatever we get up
here that's a positive value,
we're essentially going
to, if we're dividing it
by -0.1, that's like
multiplying it by -10,
so it's going to become
a very negative value,
and if instead of it
being -3.1, imagine if it
was -3.01, and this would be a 01 here.
This would be a 01 here,
and this would be a 01 here.
And so this denominator,
you're dividing by -0.01,
it's going to be even
larger negative value,
so you're going to
approach negative infinity.
So it's going to be one
of these two choices.
Now let's think about what happens
as we approach x from
the positive direction,
and that's what this
notation over there means,
this superscript on the right hand
side, the positive direction,
so we're going to approach x
from the positive direction,
and I'm going to pay
attention in particular
to the interval between -2 and -3,
because then we know
we don't have any weird
sign changes going on in the numerator.
So I care about the interval -3<x<-2.
So I can draw an open circle here
to say we're not considering
when we're at -2,
and of course we're
not going to include -3
because our function isn't defined there,
but over this interval, so x + 1 is still
going to be negative,
x +1 is still going to be negative.
If you took a -2.5 + 1,
it's going to be -1.5.
x + 2 is still going to be negative,
you're taking values that
are more negative than -2,
that are less than -2, so you add two
to that and you're still
going to be negative,
and then let's see, if you add three,
if you add three to
these values, remember,
they're greater than -3, or you could
say they're less negative than -3,
well then this is going to
give you a positive value.
This is going to give
you a positive value,
and think about it, q of,
q of, I don't know, -2.99,
what is that going to be equal to?
If you add one to that, that is -1.99,
and if you add two to that,
times, times
- 0.99
all of that over -2.99 + 3,
well that's going to be
0.01, so you're going
to get a positive value on
top and then you're going
to divide it by 0.01, that's the same
thing as multiplying
by 100, so you're going
to get larger and larger values.
You're going to approach
infinity as you get
closer and closer to it
from the right hand side.
So q of x is going to
approach positive infinity.
So this is the choice that is correct.
This one is wrong, this says we're going
to approach negative
infinity, so that's incorrect,
and we will go with that choice.